als kind wollte anka schmid tiger und
löwen bändigen
die abenteuerliche welt des zirkus hatte
es ihr angetan
stattdessen hat sie nun einen film über
dem thüringen gemacht das war die
kultserie über eine artistenfamilie in
den sechziger siebziger jahren in
thüringen quer durch europa porträtiert
anka schmid den world women gentle bis
erzählt von einer lebensform von einem
der letzten großen abenteuer heutzutage
besonders für frauen mit sich um alles
was im haus ansteht
aber in der manege bin ich durch
selbstbewusstsein braucht sie in der
männerwelt zirkus eine russin cent bären
mit ihrer tochter
das leben mit den raubtieren ist raum
sind als ich mach es weiterhin das sind
wirklich hier mit dem instinkt und
unberechenbar reagieren wenn irgendetwas
passiert es ist schuss frei als
zusätzliches abenteuer avatar jetzt mal
war microsoft anka schmid fokussiert in
ihrem film ganz bewusst auf die frauen
zeigt den schönen schein der glitzerwelt
hinter dem der alltag oft besonders
trostlos wirkt im schweizer circus royal
lernte sie carmen zander kennen die
dompteurin reist als ein frau
unternehmen durch die weltgeschichte
einsam ist das abseits des rampenlichts
auf sich allein gestellt ist die frühere
ddr leistungssportlerin aber auch in der
manege
die angst ist ein ständiger begleiter
aber es ist ganz wichtig dass ich schon
nur auf einen blick welche tiger
anschaut sie was signalisiert er mir was
sagt er mir und ich muss darauf sofort
eingehen können und das ist eine sekunde
nur na und wenn ich da kein wissen hätte
und ich sage verstehe was er mir sagt
kann ich ja nicht reagieren und wenn da
missverständnis entsteht und ich falsch
reagiert kann das tödlich für mich
abenteuerlich waren auch die
dreharbeiten jedoch weniger für das
filmteam die größte gefahr ist dass du
ihre telefone team nach und was nicht
eine kamera bewegt sich so kann man
bewegt sich langsam
das ist ihr beruf die piste nicht das
mikrofon
das hat ja so einen bild zaubert oder
dass ich mit tiger oder dass ich ein
spiel objekt also das heißt wir sind
abgelenkt durch filmteam es ist
beeindruckend wie nah anka schmid
menschen und tieren kommt dabei zeigt
sie auch momente die brutal wirken ist
so viel dominanz noch in ordnung
andere länder in europa haben
mittlerweile rauke dressur verboten das
geht der filmemacherin aber zu weit
es ist ein derbes mit dieser zirkus
antiquierte hierarchien kompromisslose
arbeit und brutale einsamkeit gehören
dazu
anka schmid faszination bleibt ihre
schätze ring macht den film zu einer
hommage an ein aussterbendes chandra
ermöglicht sich so beinahe die erfüllung
ihres kindheitstraums